no it's a rather scaredy cat way to look
at things so what if it's online so what
if it's on the phone so what if it's on
the street its life and what we forget
about the Internet is that it actually I
think makes life in some ways more
intense and more social you know as I
was testing search engines through the
years i would use like other guys the
friends of my old girlfriends names and
i would go through and search my
girlfriend's most of them didn't have
any google shadow i have a long google
google shadow because i have a blog and
a big ego but one of my old girlfriends
found me now that could not have
happened before google and we had
conversations i apologize for being a
bad guy in the old days it and that was
a kind of a gift but as I thought about
this I realized that living online with
these constant connections could even
change the nature of friendship if I
were 17 years old today and I was bad to
my high school girlfriend that's going
to live with me because she's gonna know
where I am I'm gonna know where she is I
can't get away from her and I almost
wonder whether that changes the way I
behaved the president of google has said
that perhaps we need to be have a law
that allows us to all change our names
at age 21 so we can forget the past but
we won't be able to so our paths will
stay with us and I think that will make
us better behaved and we're badly
behaved well you know what we have
mutually assured humiliation because i
had my drunk picture and you have your
drunk picture and that's life so what's
the big deal inhaling or not inhaling
won't be so important in presidential
campaigns as we go forward so living
online means we're living with people
it's a mistake to think that the
internet is a medium that's media people
projecting their view of the world on
the internet the internet is not it's a
connection machine doc Searls the
blogger says it's a place where we talk
so when you realize the internet is
really about connecting people with
information and people with each other
it intensifies life it's better to have
it I get to meet people around the world
I never could have met I get to stay in
touch with old friends I couldn't have
done I get to do more business I get to
hear more ideas the internet is a
distilled life it's a wonderful life
it's more efficient I'm not you know
worrying about what the programmer put
on TV today I'm choosing my own stuff so
living on the internet i think is living
much
Oh